hey everyone we're here with sunny Jane
from Sun genomics hi Alan thanks for
having me I'm excited to continue
talking about the microbiome yes and now
we're gonna be talking about what
exactly the microbiome is and also kind
of especially in the most recent years
it's kind of now we've started to
analyze it more and understand how it's
applicable to our lives yeah so the
first thing that food or nutrition
encounters as it's going through our
digestive process for absorption is the
microbiome believe it or not so there
are microbes living inside our bodies
there's trillions of them if not more
microbial cells in our bodies then there
are human cells that's always crazy one
to think about I know I mean we didn't
know this maybe five ten years ago or
fully respect how much contribution that
these microbes have to our own human
physiology and what we've learned is
that there's there's trillions of these
microbes inside of our bodies and they
have their own DNA as we have our own
DNA and that DNA is called the
microbiome so then what as we understand
the DNA in the microbiome like what does
that end up telling us well we can now
understand through this evolution of
technology that's occurred where you can
analyze DNA and large amounts of DNA
really really fast and by doing so
instead of having to isolate individual
microbes on a petri dish that you might
have learned in school we can now just
take a small little sample isolate the
DNA and then just define every single
DNA base pair that's coming out into a
particular microbe and that gives you a
full idea of all the microbes in that
sample and then your gut and those
things play a large role in digestion
nutritional absorption and even chronic
conditions and then how does this like
the size of this is about you know it's
like kind of like what's located right
under our like
lungs and right above kind of our pelvis
that whole area is kind of like the gut
the microbiome yeah it's a right past
the stomach you enter into the small
intestine and the small intestine as you
can see in the graphic here is a very
long stretch of organ and through that
in in strut entire stretch you have
certain changes in pH you have changes
in different categories of microbes that
are present and there's different
nutritional absorption occurring across
that that stretch and then you enter
into the large colon or the large
intestine and you have different
microbes that live there and you have
different digestive and absorption
happening there that's crazy so there's
a different pH and a different microbe
microbes that are living right where the
stomach meets the small intestine versus
and they're like the large intestine
versus in the middle of the small
intestine as in it's just most of the
nutrients are getting absorbed at the
beginning of the small intestine as and
that's the kind of like where the food
is most like fresh and ready to start
absorbing into the blood and then like
the microbe will change throughout the
small and the large intestine then yeah
and you can capture all that now through
simple testing through DNA testing and
you'll be able to see what you know
microbe was present anywhere through
this entire stretch and by being able to
see that and understand that you can
understand your digestive capability and
and what would be needed to improve that
and we're gonna get into that in our
next video about what exactly we can do
to improve the gut microbiome awesome
thanks everyone for checking out this
video with Sun genomics and catch us on
another video soon thanks thanks